all right guys it is time to have a
conversation
that I predict many in the audience are
not going to like I have seen this trend
over the last few days as I and others
have been covering CPAC the Republican
conference over the weekend and the
trend is people saying hey progressives
Trump is over forget about Trump don't
talk about Trump don't talk about CPAC
never mention Donald Trump again he lost
he's gone he's irrelevant now I must
operate in reality
and the reality right now is that there
are two major political parties in the
United States one of them is the
Republican party and their candidate
Donald Trump received 74 million votes
in 2020. that very same Donald Trump
easily crushed everyone in the CPAC
straw poll from this weekend which we
looked at yesterday the numbers are not
even close now I know a lot of people
want to wish or do wish Donald Trump was
irrelevant but no one other than
trumpian Republican Governor Ron
DeSantis is even polling more than one
percent right now in the CPAC straw poll
as you can see in the results that we
have on screen
Donald Trump pulled 70 percent in the
CPAC straw poll Ron DeSantis was at 21
and then you've got a bunch of one
percenters Rand Paul Nikki Haley Ted
Cruz and Tucker Carlson of those people
I think only Tucker Carlson even has a
shot at significantly growing his level
of support Dr Carlson decided I want to
grow my level of support and maybe look
at being the Republican nominee
partially because of his media platform
so I wish Trump weren't relevant but
ignoring him won't make him irrelevant
Trump is in complete and total control
of the Republican Party he owns the
Republican party right now we could wish
him uh uh we we could wish that he'd be
irrelevant but he's not and much the
same way that not paying attention in
2016 is partially what led him to
winning the Republican primary and
subsequently becoming president of the
United States pretending that this guy
doesn't have an incredibly devout
fervent feverish following could
potentially lead to the exact same thing
in 2024 and there's people already
emailing me saying they don't want to
hear it I was one of the people that
made this mistake in 2015 and 2016. I
overestimated the intelligence of the
Republican electorate when you
overestimate their intelligence you get
crushed and I never thought they would
be so ignorant that they would make
Trump their nominee but they did
and then many on the left myself
included didn't really take the threat
of trump seriously in the general
election and next thing you know he's
president of the United States he's
mishandling covid he's humiliating us
globally and the rest is history now
Trump won by very few votes in a few
States in 2016. he lost by slightly more
in 2020 but again it was not that many
votes and not that many states that
pushed the Electoral Victory to Joe
Biden the popular vote victory of course
Biden ran away with and this level of
devotion from the Republican Party who
were activated by imaginary threats of
Joe Biden's communism and Joe Biden's
Marxism and Kamala Harris's socialism
they are ripe for crushing Democrats in
2022 and 2024. now political scientist
Rachel bidikoffer has been writing about
this quite a bit she feels people aren't
paying enough attention we're going to
speak to Rachel I believe it's on
Thursday this week and and that's
assuming she's fully recovered from her
appendicitis she's been tweeting about
it we wish her well uh and she is very
concerned about this as well I
understand being sick of trump and being
completely embarrassed that he's still
getting this adulation and support from
the Republican party but this guy is
very much in control right now is it sad
that these are the people leading the
CPAC straw poll right now of course it's
sad
is it globally humiliating that after
everything we've suffered including I
mean the deadly mismanagement of the
covid pandemic that Trump did is it
globally humiliating that he's polling
70 of the CPAC straw poll of course it
is of course it is it's a global
humiliation without a doubt but this is
what it is and he may win and we don't
gain anything by ignoring it and in fact
I think we're more at risk of that
happening if we just pretend that Trump
is a bygone at this point in time if you
disagree with me I want to hear from you
but it can't be a personal attack guys
it really can't uh if you if you believe
that the left ignoring Trump
would make a difference we disagree but
I'm open to hearing why and we'll have
more about this particular story on our
Instagram if you're not following the
David Pacman show on Instagram at this
point I don't know what you're doing
crossword puzzles maybe which are fun by
the way but Instagram is cool too uh
follow us on Instagram at davidpackman
show we will take a quick break and be
back with much more right after this
I'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is Helix sleep I sleep on
a helix mattress at home I absolutely
love it and that's why I reached out to
them about sponsoring the David Pacman
show buying a mattress in the past was
always a huge guessing game for me I
didn't know what I actually needed I
didn't know what I would like but Helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness I generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress Helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both GQ and Wired Magazine it
is well deserved I can tell you
firsthand every Helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but I know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free when you go to the link right
underneath this video